Une fois par an..
.. Lors de la pleine lune
Un youtubeur se transforme en immense Tryharder et termine un jeu extrêmement difficile..
Levez les yeux. La lune est pleine vous savez donc ce que ça veut dire...
Ok gamin mon nom est..
Gros bolosse qui a son pseudo marqué sur sa veste
Ok les amis aujourd'hui j'ai envie de "tryhard", j'ai envie de mettre à l'épreuve mon skill hein , qui est comme ça
Level Down qu'est-ce que c'est? C'est un jeu de plateforme composé de 20 niveaux
Quand tu perds un niveau, tu retournes au niveau d'avant
Simple, efficace, le "tryhard" est présent
Ok c'est parti!
Donc là, c'est le level 1
Logiquement, c'est un peu le level tuto un peu pété
Ok on a le droit à un double saut
Mec, si ça se trouve la vidéo elle va vraiment durer 2 minutes!
Le skill est en nous je le sens aujourd'hui
J'avais vraiment envie de "tryhard" et d'habitude..
Nan mec..
ça va se compliquer hyper vite, regardez
Déjà Level 3, voilà
Nan ça va encore.
Nan je pense que je m'enflamme
Aaaah ok on part direct sur un.. D'accord
Donc à mon avis faut que je parte sur un double jump pour atterrir dessus
Ah putain!
Putain mec level 5 je perd déjà!
Ah je me suis enflammé de ouf en vous disant qu'on allait y arriver vite
Non je rigole
Après tout..
Je suis un tryharder
Comment je vais rager si j'y arrive pas
Faut vraiment arriver tout au bout
Ah mais non!
Je comprend pas comment on peut y arriver
Non en vrai je m'enflamme
En fait quand je parle ça me déconcentre
Du coup c'est pour ça que dans toutes mes vidéos je suis nul *bégaille*c'est parce que je parle
Oui ! Monsieur c'est passé
Alors mon gars, les p'tits canons, là ça on connait bien
Ca fait 8 ans qu'ça existe, paye ton originalité
Ok, j'vais attendre là
Maitenant on est bon ! Et là mec ça va se compliquer sa mère je le sais ...
Oh !
Oui, ok putain comment j'me suis concentré mon gars ! Ca c'est quoi ? C'est qu'ça s'casse ?
Roh les bâtards!
Attends, mais d'jà le level il dura 20 mille ans mec sans déconner!
Ah d'accord en plus les plateformes sur lesquelles on rebondit.. se cassent , d'accord , alors qu'il y a les flammes qu'arrivent
ok..
Level 9, il nous reste 11 levels!
11 levels..
Alors ça, comment ça marche?
Et voilà, on est passé!
WOOOOH!
Level 10!
Ok, là c'est le piège.. D'accord. Putain mec,  c'est hyper chaud!
Sans déconner, what the fuck?
Ok..
Et là, c'est la sortie, ok on est bien!
Level 11!
LEVEL 11!
Oui..
OUI!
Ok..
Level 12, level 12!
Plus que 9!
Mec, comment ça va se compliquer
Par contre, j'avoue... OH PUTAIN!!!
AAHHHH!!!
J'y suis allé en mode yolo mon gars!
Mais des fois ça marche !
OUIIIIII!
Quoi?!
Alors là d'accord!
ça c'est gratuit le développeur il avait le seum j'étais entrer d'carrer son jeu
Ok de retour level 12
Alors, j'aimerais bien juste comprendre pourquoi j'suis mort
Juste une explication, peut-être, hein? On a au moins l'droit à ça quand on...
MEEEEEURT!
Pourquoi j'ai pas été youtubeur heu.. cuisine mec? Franchement ça aurait été plus détente
Ah d'accord j'avais dût me prendre les flammes en fait, j'ai même pas vu, ok
Vous avez dû bien me prendre pour un f*p de rageux
et vous avez bien raison
Ok c'partit
Oh put*in ! Oh c'était express, quoi !
Mais j'ai un double.. Nan là par contre si ma barre espace heu...
*tappe sur le clavier*
PUT*IN PLUS LONG! Plus long steuplait !
OH MON DIEU!
C'est quoi ce système là? Ah ça va m'attirer vers l'eau j'vais devoir esquiver ?
Ah d'accord j'ai des sauts illimités en fait quand j'sors de cette substance. Oké
Ah Flappy Bird! C'est exactement le même mécanisme que Flappy Bird mon gars ! *rires*
On a grillé la posture.. Oh oui c'est un level facile de transition ça fait plaisir
ET BIIIIIIIIIM !
Level 16 mec level 16
J'avais mis un mois en troisième pour atteindre ce level là sur WO
Big up pour Lucas 2011
Oh put*in j'ai failli mourir.. C'pas grave, c'pas grave
J'SUIS PASSÉ LEVEL 17 !!
Ah put*in il nous lâche... AH LE BÂTARD il nous lâche direct sur un truc sale quoi
ça commence à être un peu compliqué...
Si j'perds le level d'après j'vais chialer de refaire ce put*in de level là, mais bon
Ok, là y'a la sortie qui arrive nan ça va en fait ça va, ok
F******ck c'est quoi ça?
Attends j'analyse j'analyse j'analyse
Oké. On est bon
J'avais pas vu. J'avais pas vu j'avais pas anticipé. PUT*IN NAN C'LEVEL IL EST CHIANT!
IL EST CHIANT!
Oké.
NAAAAAN!
Nan mais c'est trop dur ça ! Nan vous avez pas le droit
Put****in, on est bloqué level 17, quoi
J'pense j'vais vraiment péter une durite, comme dirait, euh... mon daron
Quand j'vais perdre à ce level là, qu'on est entrain de faire
Ok, là j'ai compris comment ça marche en fait
Oh put*in c'est super long mais c'est... AAAAH!
Y'en avait un j'avais même pas vu, oh put*in
AAAAAHHHH NAAAAN!
ça y est j'pète ma durite, j'suis entrain de péter ma durite, ça y est.
Ma durite est là. Ma durite est là.
Ma durite est caAAAAA
*inspire*
*incompréhensible*
AAAAAHHHH!
J'ai mal à la durite.
Mais, une fois tous les cinq ans
un nuage passait devant la pleine lune
Et le skill du tryhardeur baissait à vue d'oeil.
Va-t-il réussir malgré le nuage?
POOOOOW!
WAW!
ça commence direct!
OOOOOOOOOOOOOHHHHHHHHH!
Ah les bâtaaaaaaaaards
Oh
NAAN! Mais c'est impossible !
*expire*
C'est quoi? C'est quoi faut faire quoi? UN ANANAS QUI VOLE!
What the f*ck? Qu'est-ce que je dois faire?!
Qu'est-ce que j'dois faire?
Ah faut qu'j'esquive, oh put*in ça.. oh put***in
Un dirait tellement un super smash bros mec!
J'veux vraiment pas refaire celui d'avant
Ok faut qu'je saute j'ai compris y'a une notion de 3D oké
OOOOOHHHH..
j'arrive plus à..
Ah d'accord ! ça va être ça plein de fois ! d'accord c'est plein d'épreuves !
put*in de MAAAAAAAAA
On repasse à.. au truc d'avant du coup put*in nan nan!
C'est le niveau final mais y'a quand même un peu 6 levels en un si tu vois la douille, hein !
Hop... hop ... hop...
NAAAAAN!
Oh nan, nan, nan, NAN !
Put*in on est tombés bien bas. On est tombés bien bas
Est-ce qu'on va tomber encore plus bas c'est ça le risque
Put*innnnn mais j'bloque à c'niveau d'M*RDE!
J'commence à avoir mal aux yeux à force de les garder ouverts de pas cligner des yeux mec
Vous connaissez ma capacité
à garder les yeux ouverts pendant longtemps
YES !
Aller aller
On est en plein milieu (x4)
YES!
Aller, ALLER
OH MAIS NAN !
MAIS NAN !
Oh naaan..
Nan, c'était... naaan..
NAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAN
musique de m*rde..
avec cette grosse musique de M*RDE là
Put*in
J'le fais sans son. J'le fais sans son ça m'a soulé
J'arrive plus j'arrive plus
*incompréhensible*
C'est bon ça va j'suis au milieu là, ok
Put*in...
aller...aller... ALLER !
PU-T*IN
Naaaaan, naaan...
Pitié, j'vais chialer j'vous jure j'vais pleurer
*tappe sur le bureau*
NAN ! MAIS NAN, MAIS NAN !
Nan mais déjà, déjà c'est quoi c'put*in d'jeu l'mec il t'arnaque il dit "dernier level dernier level" mon gars y'a..
*mets un coup de pied dans la chaise*
"Après tout, j'suis un tryharder"
*souffle*
Là
Là, si j'perds celui-là
Soit j'casse un truc de ouf
Soit j'fais un AVC
C'est partit.
ça m'tire les sourcils c'est chiant. C'est chiant.
Bandeau atengo poser on va le poser
Voilà ambiance posée tamisée
Ok. La corde à sauter on comprend rien parce que la 3D est trop mal faite
Ok j'suis passé c'est l'deuxième level. Deuxième level
Avec des put*ins de lasers en plus. Oké
Put*in.
Ok. C'est bon. C'est fait.
... What the f*ck..
WHAT THE F*CK
What the f*ck fallait faire quoi?!
Ok. C'est maintenant que faut sauter d'office c'est maintenant.
Ok c'est bon ça va être le truc final
J'vois rien.. Oké là y'a un trou d'accord à chaques fois y'aura un trou et ça va être de plus en plus..
Oké d'accord j'ai compris
Ah d'accord oké. Ah d'accord oké !
Nan mais attends mais c'est imp..
put*in...
D'accord faut que j'aille maintenant, comme ça c'est plus facile de manipuler maintenant qu'après
J'ai compris oké j'y suis maintenant ensuite c'est en haut, oké
Ensuite j'vais revenir un peu vers le milieu
Ah m*rde c'est en haut à gauche put*in. C'pas grave c'pas grave c'pas grave
Oké
C'est bon j'ai réussi. C'est finit?
Nan c'pas finit c'pas finit. C'est pas grave
Oké put*in mec ça part en... On comprend rien
J'comprends rien du tout j'ai réussi j'sais pas comment j'ai réussi mais j'ai rien compris
D'accord faut qu'j'passe là-dedans? Comment j'vais passer là-dedans?
Faut qu'j'trouve un p'tit... Ah put*in
J'allais dire faut que j'trouve un créneau bah voilà dans mon cul l'créneau
Ok j'ai réussi.. Là c'est les quadrillages
Ensuite là, j'sais plus ce que c'est.. Ah c'est..
Mec
J'ai jamais été dans un état comme ça devant un jeu vidéo
J'm'en batait les c*uilles de la vidéo quoi désolé c'était carrément un manque de respect
J'voulais juste finir ce... J'ai les mains glacées mec!
Tellement j'tryhard
Tellement j'donne toute la puissance à mon cerveau pour qu'il passe ce truc ! *rires*
Mec c'est la fin?
Genre là c'est terminé pour de vrai?
Y'a pas de pièges, de trucs nuls, euh c'est.. vraiment finit?
"Merci d'avoir joué" Oh meeeec
Franchement j'ai qu'un truc à dire..
"Easy win"
Les amis n'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plut
J'ai vraiment cru que j'allais... annuler la vidéo tellement ça m'a rendu fou
Bon bref
Eh bah voià j'espère que ça vous a plu n'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plu
On s'retrouve très vite dans une prochaine
Franchement... tranquille easy pèpère easy
Put*in maintenant quand j'me ferais défoncer sur OverWatch j'vais vachement relativiser
par rapport à c'que j'viens de me prendre là
C'est un challenge physique
Merci père de m'avoir légué ce bandeau...
"Artengo"
J'vous l'offre en retour, si vous voulez essayer ce jeu tenez vous en aurez besoin.
Vas-y, baisse la tête, voilà j'te le mets comme ça
Autour du cou
A bientôt dans une nouvelle vidéos. Portez-vous bien. Ciao tout le monde peace.